hello there enemies of the state i'm
dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message for today october 7 20
21 we've got a big show for you today
we're doing a q a we're going to do a
little bit of covering this complete
anti-science lunatic over at cnn but
before i do anything else i have to
address something okay because yesterday
on the show
i compared rashida talib one of the
members of the squab squad this is a you
know chronic liar
evil bad bad woman who basically
admitted masks or nonsense she only does
it because you know the republicans are
standing right there and they might
expose her [ __ ] i compared her to a
cat
okay i said she was a c word people were
freaking out then i said cat and we
looked in the comments and i looked in
my email and i got a lot of email
yesterday a lot of comments people
saying dave you're too harsh on cats not
all cats are evil not all kitty litter
causes women to go insane there are nice
cats out there maybe you should get a
cat you should spend more time around
cats etc etc
so i talked to the team about it and we
thought we'd go and adopt a cat and we'd
have a reuben report cat
so i went to the local shelter yesterday
to pick up a cat we actually took some
video
hey kitty kitty hey kitty kitty
[Music]
yeah sorry cats are insane and they make
people insane i don't know what to tell
you we didn't take that cat we did not
take that cat uh okay as i said guys we
got a little video from leanna when
she is
one of the chief uh medical
correspondents on cnn and she's just a
complete maniac we're going to get to
that just a second then uh we are doing
a q a and we got dozens of questions
submitted at
reubenreport.locals.com before i get to
any of that though let's play that cat
thing again that was kind of funny
hey kitty kitty hey kitty kitty
[Music]
[Music]
i mean clyde would not have been happy
with me if i had brought that monster
back home and that's obviously not an
old internet video from 20 years ago
that clearly happened just yesterday
uh guys let's talk about uprising food
for a second you know you all know how
much i love food and for those of you
who have been tuning into my show over
the past couple of years you know that
i've had various guests who've talked
about how our food system is
fundamentally broken and making us sick
at scale fortunately the people at
uprising food are fixing that uprising's
mission is to liberate all of us from a
broken food system that's stealing our
health they've cracked the code on
healthy bread we received the starter
bundle and david and i ate all the bread
soon after it arrived a little cream
cheese little everything seasoning not
bad we were really surprised that the
bread that is this healthy tastes this
good with only two net carbs per serving
six grams of protein and nine grams of
fiber uprising food covers paleo to
clean keto to simple low carb to high
fiber to dairy free to grain free
lifestyles all uprising products are
baked with real superfood ingredients
almonds mct oil apple cider vinegar
egg white psyllium husk and olive oil
uprising has absolutely nailed the taste
factor on both their sourdough s cubes
and the crunch factor on their newly
launched freedom chips love that name
which tastes like those old school rye
chips that you dig uprising is offering
our listeners ten dollars off the
starter bundle that includes two super
fruit super few super food cubes and
four packs of freedom chips to try go to
uprisingfood.com ruben and the discount
will be automatically applied at checked
out that's
u-p-r-i-s-i-n-g food dot com slash
reuben to get 10 bucks off your first
purchase of the starter bundle and now
back to me okay so
look
cnn is a propaganda network
i don't even know who they're working
for at this point maybe they're just
trying to make everybody dumber or more
afraid or just glued to the television
because everyone thinks the world is
ending and they've got to keep them in
that constant state of panic but they've
got this woman her name is dr leanna wen
she is one of the medical correspondents
on cnn she's one of these people that
they bring on probably once a day to
scare the hell out of everybody and
she's really sort of just the worst sort
of authoritarian lunatic her pedigree by
the way she is a former uh planned
parenthood president okay just saying
she's the current public health
professor at george washington
university as i said a cnn medical
analyst well now
listen to her talking about you
dangerous dirty scary unvaccinated
people
canada just issued a covet 19 vaccine
mandate for anyone over the age of 12
traveling on a plane or a train we've
spoken about this idea before i wonder
what's a better strategy playing to
someone's fear using that kind of
marketing campaign we just showed or
making the vaccine a requirement for
more things like traveling should the us
be more like canada
yes we should we really need every tool
at our disposal at this point we've
already tried incentives we tried
outreach and education we should
continue doing that but at this point
vaccine requirements are the way to go
vaccine requirements in workplaces as
we've seen have been very effective and
i also think that for domestic travel
for interstate travel for planes trains
interstate buses things that are within
the jurisdiction of president biden and
the federal government i really do think
that it's time to put those requirements
too first it's going to make playing and
train travel a lot safer but also
especially with holidays coming it will
be a powerful incentive for people to
say look you can stay unvaccinated if
you want but you're not going to be able
to travel to see your family
all right leanne when just real quick
just go [ __ ] yourself you're not telling
me who i can see and when i can see them
and i can see my family for the holidays
and you have no authority over me and
you're a ridiculous awful person uh
that's number one now we're going to
show you a little b-roll here because
she said that uh you know these planes
they've got to be safer the planes now
we tried to find some information let's
hear a little video
every time you get on a plane they're
telling you they're spraying they've got
that special light and they're look that
woman has gloves and she's there's a
petri dish and then there's that thing
and she's got a swab and look at what
they're doing over there these people
planes are very safe guys joking aside
every time you get on a plane they
that's what they tell you we take care
of 99.999 percent of everything the air
is filtered there i can't find any study
that is showing that covet is being
transmitted on planes these are the
worst sort of fear mongering maniacs and
by the way the host of that cnn show i
don't even know who that is the way she
set up the question was was actually
evil
because in essence she's saying what's a
better strategy playing to fear or
forcing them to do things as if those
are the two things all we can do with
people at this point you know these
morons these morons out there that are
dare making a choice for themselves oh
we do can we play to their fear really
let's scare the [ __ ] out of them i'm
sorry about the f words today ma
let's scare the hell out of them right
or or let's just demand that they do
stuff and then you bring on this maniac
former head of planned parenthood uh to
actually spout anti-science
nonsense the implication being that if
you go on planes that kovitz being
transmitted on planes we cannot find any
info on that
and buses they don't want you on buses
and they don't want you on railway or
anything else there is something very
nefarious with this leanne woman
something is not right there and the
fact that cnn is putting on these people
to scare the hell out of everybody and
if you think for a second that a year
and a half almost two years from two
weeks to flatten the curve if you think
that this has anything to do it has
nothing to do with a virus anymore don't
you get it they want to control every
part of your life
every part of your life
.002 percent of children under eighteen
die of covid and they're demanding that
all children will be vaccinated too and
they won't let you go anywhere and they
won't let you get on a plane but they're
doing it for your safety and soon
they'll bust into your house and grab
you and throw you in a cell and they'll
do it for your safety they'll feed your
fish heads once a week and they'll do it
for your safety
ugh awful human being can we show that
cat video again just so i'm in a better
mood for the q a here we go i adopted a
cat kitty hey kitty kitty
[Music]
all right that's better let's do a
little q a bradley says any chance that
fouchy and the biden administration will
follow the science and make an exemption
in the vaccine mandate for naturally
immune people
no
no and no
it just has nothing to do with reality
it has nothing to do with science they
simply don't care this is the beginning
of ushering in
a social credit system it's just obvious
at this point what was conspiracy three
years ago is obvious now they will
demand that you have this vaccine
passport and then they will check
because it'll all be on your phone what
transactions you make who you talk to do
you show up to rallies did you say
something bad about a good progressive
leader etc etc by the way if you think
what i'm saying is complete uh
conspiracy obviously i do not you might
want to check out my interview with rand
paul we taped it yesterday afternoon and
went up this morning we actually
discussed that quite a bit and he
elaborates on everything going on with
kovid and he is a doctor by the way so
he knows a bit of what he's talking
about he gets really into
uh immunity after you have covid versus
the vaccines but no they don't want that
that's why none of this makes sense do
you think it would make sense a year and
a half later to have everyone wearing
masks when they walk into malls when you
could do a rapid test right there or you
could do a temperature check of people
you could also leave people up to their
own devices you could ask people not to
come home if they're sick etc etc like
there is nothing that will turn these
people down at this point wait can you
grab the uh the fouchy box that we got i
want to show a little bit of the fouchy
box we have that fouchy box they sent us
the fouchy box the big fouchy box that
we got
the fouchy box it's in the other room
the fouchy box you know what i'm talking
about they sent us for the movie fauci
they sent us a big gift box
there's a movie a disney movie about
fouchy because this is all theater and
they sent us a gift box i'll bust out
some of the nonsense that they gave us
uh all right christina says my question
of the day is what the actual [ __ ] well
now i cursed three times today uh yeah i
get you i get you christina um
everything is just like out of control
right now it really is we gotta find the
silver lining actually in my interview
with rand paul i asked him about the
silver lining part you know what what is
it that we can do to to sort of see
that that
horizon where things will get better and
the only answer to that is that is that
maybe you can figure it out for yourself
like you've got whether that's
whether that's moving whether that's
getting your kids out of school whether
that's starting your own business
whether that's living more off the grid
like for now we are just in something
bad the the all the stuff that i've been
warning about on this show that many
other people have been warning about for
longer than me it's all kind of here
we're not in a functioning democracy
really right now we don't have a media
that checks them we have a media that
actually protects them that then you
throw big tech on top of that and yeah
it's it's a like a gremlin in water and
it's just kind of worse right like it
just
is but the but the silver lining is you
can get a lot of joy in your own
individual life and that's what i try to
do around here that's what i think my my
team tries to do uh telling my
assistant's birthday tomorrow night
we're throwing a party for helen i'm
gonna be making a freaking i got a i got
a filet mignon that's probably i don't
know it could be 12 pounds or something
and we're gonna we're gonna smoke that
baby and uh you just gotta figure out
ways to to smile throughout the madness
and enjoy life throughout the madness
moon tide says with the latest
restrictions in la are you and david
finally thinking about fleeing the state
of california look everyone keeps asking
me i know you know some of my feelings
on this which is
when this all started all of this
coveted insanity i said i was gonna
fight for this recall that was at the
beginning when there was a rumor that
there was going to be a recall then i
spent a year fighting for the recall
then i spent months you know fighting
obviously for larry elder i don't have
to repeat all the stuff about how
horribly the media media treated him and
and obviously the recall did not go well
um it's hard to paint a version
of california that looks good now to
bring this to the question previously
it's like yeah my own life's pretty good
i stay in my house i pretty much don't
leave really don't david does the food
shopping
he's a great chef we have parties we
have people over here i've got things
that i want i i got a half court
basketball court i'm happy like we're
doing all right i work from home i've
got a great team um but there is a limit
there there is a limit to living in a
place that is so out of whack with your
beliefs on top of the fact you know the
tax situation
you know you're willing to pay taxes to
live in certain places like california
for example because the weather is
really great you live in socal it's like
pretty much perfect your proximity to
the beach all that um but at some point
you're just funding your own demise and
that's what it sort of feels like to me
and also it's not that i think that like
communism will be here tomorrow where
they where they really will be like
ripping people out of their beds and
black bagging them although i wouldn't
put anything past these nut jobs it's
more that there will just be like this
this slow systemic
crushing of all of the services like we
will get more brownouts because we won't
hire the right people obviously the
education system is completely corrupt
and teaching all the backwards things
our roads won't be fixed as well as they
should be like all of the things won't
quite work um so the most honest way i
can answer that is we're really thinking
about it it's a lot i've got employees
i've got businesses like
i don't know what to do but i will say
one other thing which is
you know before this recall stuff and
everything with larry and all of the
insanity of the last year and a half i
never really considered myself a fighter
i didn't like i like talking to people i
like talking about ideas i don't really
like talking about people you know i
have to make fun of these fools like
leanne wen but like
i like talking and and exploring ideas
that's really what i like that's what
i've done on this show that's like what
i get the most joy from directly i think
and what what sort of uh you know um
sparks the most curiosity intellectually
for me um but what i realized i guess in
the last year and a half is that i am a
fighter right like i like fighting with
these people i like fighting for what is
right i didn't really know it but i know
it now so the idea of just being like
i'm packing up and going like that's
sort of against my ethos and on the
other hand you don't want to be the last
guy in dodge and you know when sometimes
sometimes the game's over and are we at
that game over point so truly like i'm
trust me i'm thinking about all these
things all the time did we not find the
fouchy box
the fouchy box you know what i'm talking
about
he doesn't know what i'm talking about
you know what i'm talking about he
didn't see the fouchy box all right i
got a box in this house filled with
fouchy merchandise from from disney
yeah we're going to find the voucher box
okay uh dissent says we talk about all
the horrible things corrupt politicians
and their celebrity buddies do we hope
that the justice system will step in and
prevail but alas nothing happens what do
you think our tipping point is yeah so
there's a theme today to the questions
um
what's the tipping point i don't know
that there will be a direct
tipping point i think a lot of people
are being red pilled right like a lot of
people
you know the more the government goes
out of control the more that cnn is
exposed as a lying news organization the
more that the new york times lies about
everybody the more that people who voted
for joe biden see inflation
go up the more that they see 3.5
trillion dollars is supposed to equal
zero the more they see the border be
overrun uh the more they see all of the
shortages that we're having i mentioned
yesterday trying to buy a couch right
now basically everything's like four
months away ah we got the uh the fouchy
box thank you very much um so it's like
people are being red-pilled i don't know
that there will be like a momentous
tipping point where things just suddenly
magically get better like something
horrible happens and they get better
it's just up to you it really is and i
know that answer is not that satisfying
and it's and especially it's not that
satisfying if it's like right now you
got to make some serious choices for
yourself like all of these people
who are confronted with do i keep my job
and go against my own
philosophy related to my medical privacy
what do i do if i can't afford to take
my kid out of school i can't homeschool
them because i have to go to work like
we are all being confronted with serious
serious stuff
but what sits with that is then you get
to think about your life seriously and
maybe we were all just sleepwalking for
these last 20 years or maybe longer in
america maybe freedom became
so ubiquitous and it was so everywhere
and we started arguing about minutia
that as freedom started slipping away we
didn't see it and now we're suddenly all
seeing it so you got a chance perhaps uh
to better yourself all right so what i
was talking about here i'm not making
this thing up i guess you weren't here
for this yesterday uh the disney which
is a giant corporation uh they've got a
movie about this fouchy guy and for some
reason they sent us a box of fouchy
stuff like if you don't think this is
all just packaged [ __ ] i've got
pouchy in a box okay so this is i guess
there's a documentary it's in
conjunction with national geographic and
disney it's like you know what if there
was a freaking pandemic and they were
really fearing that everybody's dying do
you think they'd be spending any of
their money on their fancy box and let's
see what's in this ridiculous box they'd
be putting it all to figuring out how to
solve the thing oh look at this you can
get a fouchy mask that's great oh and a
little fouchy fanny pack that's nice and
fouchy cards i'm gonna literally vomit
and fouchy chocolate although this isn't
branded fouchy oh and fouchy popcorn so
they want you to have chocolate and
popcorn because that way you can become
fat and die of coping more popcorn
fouchy the book oh my god oh oh i mean
this is this is absolutely extraordinary
fouchy the [ __ ] candy box that's what
they're giving you
get me the numbers on on uh overweight
people diana kovid they fauci fauci you
got your chocolate you got your popcorn
you got your gummy bears and your sour
patch kids and you can put it all in
your fanny pack while you're sitting
there you fat freak and then you can put
your uh your soda right here in the
fouchy uh oh my god and what's this
they're blissey i don't even know what
this is scrunchies scrunchy
oh it's scrunchy you can put a scrunchie
in your hair too
there's no business like show business
there's no business i know
all right let's move on uh okay we got
ma here thank you for the numbers i'm
doing live fact checking right here
models estimate that uh
271 000 about 30
of the hospitalizations due from kovid
were attributed to obesity someone may
want to tell
with his popcorn and his candy
and his chocolate
that obesity has something to do with
dying of cobalt and you know disney like
it's
it's theater you guys
[Music]
it's theater
what's next
landon are you feeling a national
there's candy all over the place here
now are you feeling a national divorce
is inevitable um
look i hope not but i sort of don't see
a way around it we have intractable
positions that don't seem like they can
be met you either believe in freedom
where you believe in endless state
control and you believe in
ever-encroaching government to decide
everything that you do or you loosely
believe in freedom
do you
loosely believe that people can make
decisions for themselves you think that
humans can't create these systems that
know more than humans themselves
versus more more more an expert class
and lies and [ __ ] and control
how do you marry those two things i
don't think you can so we're at it we're
at an odd moment and i would say this is
probably
a moment that hasn't been seen in this
country probably since the civil war
right before the civil war when there
was talk of going to war north south we
got problems here right and what did
abraham lincoln want to do abraham
lincoln felt that we've got to keep the
union together and he did it and it
worked for about 200 years maybe it's
not quite working anymore i don't know
what a horrible thing to have to say and
by the way if we if we had some sort of
national divorce we'd end up at war with
each other
mostly because the blue states would
constantly be at war with the red states
the red states would say hey leave us
alone you know we're doing our thing we
don't like you guys we don't really want
anything to do you're welcome to visit
but you can't have all our stuff but the
blue states which will be failing
cesspools of of
absolute garbage will constantly well
they're going to go wait a minute those
guys have money and they're white
supremacists over there and we want all
their stuff so then we'll be we'll be in
perpetual war so i think we all got to
be careful about what we ask for at the
moment
joe says what do you think of the
long-term effects of the current
democratic policies crt uh mass and
vaccine mandates extreme spending will
be well i think i just sort of answered
that in the previous question we may
just be heading off a cliff here you
like it's just
those two things can't exist in the same
system like i want everyone to control
me all the time and i want to be told
what to do and i don't want to think and
i want to be some sort of automaton
versus
i don't know
i don't know the meaning of life i'm
doing the best i can let me see if i can
figure something out and you know live
freely like
it's hard it's hard to put those two
things together wayne says one trillion
dollar coin yeah did you hear about this
the fed wants to print a one trillion
dollar coin to like help with the debt
it's all nonsense first off they did
that in the simpsons like most things
they did it in the simpsons about 15
years ago
like printing one of these crazy coins
but it's like no coin that you print is
worth a trillion dollars
next question uh
kylie says uh no question just wanted to
tell you that i went and got my nails
done yesterday and while i was picking
out my color the salon owner was
watching one of your videos you're
making a difference in the world dave
thank you for what you do thank you for
that and thank you nail person uh wjb
says let's go brandon that's not a
question but i agree let's go brandon
elijah says who would you least like to
sit next to on a plane
journey to california aoc ilhan omar or
the current leader of the taliban
um
i mean well aoc and ilhanom are
obviously worse than the taliban so i'll
sit next to that guy out of aoc and
ilhan omar i mean they're both horrible
they're horrible
aoc the that shrill voice and she never
stops talking i mean i think ilhan omar
is is a true vile
person and a racist and is here to
destroy the country but i feel like aoc
talks more and is there anything worse
than sitting next to someone on a plane
who won't shut up so i can't believe it
but if i was on a plane back to
california and i had to choose between
aoc
or the current leader of the taliban i
choose ilhan omar
you learn something about yourself every
day you know you really do nate says do
you have any plans for halloween and
what is your favorite 80s horror movie
great question so for halloween actually
i will be at the national conservative
conference in orlando
uh and uh there's a ton of great people
that that are gonna be there uh peter
thiel is speaking and marco rubio is
speaking and ayan hirsi ali and chris
ruffo it's really like an all-star
selection of the type of people that i
want to sort of help build a good future
with for this country so i'm very
excited uh the event starts on the 31st
and it goes to the second i believe
peter thiel is opening it on the 31st i
think i'm closing it on the second but
i'll be there for the full days i'm
going to do a whole bunch of interviews
there i think locals is partly
sponsoring the event so that's where i
will be for halloween what will i dress
up as that's uh well let's you know i
guess i could dress up as
aoc or something like i'll dress up as
fouchy and eat candy
my favorite 80s horror movie by far the
original nightmare on elm street by far
i remember seeing that i was probably in
third or fourth grade uh and i remember
seeing it at a sleepover with my buddy
john and arie and just like the gore and
freddie and you got to bury his bones in
the boiler room downstairs and the glove
and the sweater
it was just oh
yeah i was like obsessed we were
obsessed with nightmare on elm street so
i would say that is by far
a 80s horror nightmare on elm street
final question naomi have you noticed
seinfeld is on netflix comedy has
returned yes holla freaking lula
hallelujah you know what i mean
hallelujah
seinfeld's back you know seinfeld was on
hulu for a couple years and then i think
in towards the end of june they took it
off
and it was being purchased by netflix
whatever
netflix purchased it for hulu's got to
be really upset because people still
watch it people really do watch it it
stands the test of time so there was
like a two month window
basically well almost three months
actually probably july august september
where there was no seinfeld available
streaming it is now back on netflix but
have you guys noticed this that they did
something i i checked it
we did a little searching uh the quality
of seinfeld on netflix is pretty crappy
they did something related to like the 4
3
you know the aspect ratio whatever that
is so it's kind of granular and it looks
really old so supposedly they're going
to fix it at some point it looks it
looks pretty terrible
let's see oh
this is uh live chat so you know one of
the things we're doing now guys is you
can live chat
during the show if you join us at
reubenreport.locals.com so we've got
people in there live chatting and helen
my assistant is in there talking to
people and it's a very fun way of
interacting with the show and i said
yesterday that you know let's
occasionally we'll bust out some
comments from the live chat so shark
attack no stack attack says taste that
chocolate and candy might be laced with
the vaccine
wouldn't that be something they sent
this to all the anti-vaxx right wing
maniacs who really love
pink gummy bears and then they put the
vaccine in there
look at all this crap this crap from
disney they sent me a box full of crap
let's give this crap away you know what
if you want some of this crap i'll give
it to ruben report community members you
want this crappy book we'll send it to
you you want the chocolate i don't need
the chocolate
although compartes is actually a pretty
there's a chocolate store in l.a i don't
know i haven't been there in years i'm
probably not allowed in anymore but
it is a good chocolate i don't want the
popcorn
um this box of candy like i don't want
that i'm gonna just send this to you
guys you want a fouchy fanny pack like
walking around with a fouchy fanny pack
pathetic and a fouchy mask
fouchy
guys uh my 20 minute interview we did a
little short little interview with rand
paul yesterday it is up on youtube right
now part two of my interview with blake
masters who's running for senate in
arizona is up right now as well and
tomorrow we're doing a news recap uh and
we got a couple new people we're gonna
introduce you to we wanted to get a few
people from sort of different little
news organizations that i think are
doing nice work we've got libby emins
from post millennial you'll recognize
her she's a frequent guest on tucker
carlson uh my buddy chad prather with
the blaze i've never had him on believe
it or not and rav aurora who's a young
guy writing for the new york post and
really doing some great stuff so we
thought we'd introduce you to some new
people as always you can play along at
reubenreport.locals.com
and you know what guys i'm so fired up
from all of this and we're going to send
this to people to in the community if
anyone wants any of this crap i'm going
to get you guys chipotle today what do
you say
you want the you want the extra glock
extra glock all right extra glock for
everybody all right guys see you
tomorrow